this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and my name is ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists
today we're going to talk about mental
health we're going to talk about the
psychology of healing
we're going to talk about consciously
creating a healthy relationship with
yourself
and with others and we're going to do
that with dr nicole lapera
dr nicole thanks for being here thank
you both for having me oh my gosh
so talk to me about the holistic
psychologist
how did you how did you get into this
line of work i evolved into this line of
work i think is the simplest
answer joshua to that question
clinically
i'm a trained psychologist so i had the
practice for several years
on the human side of things i very much
relate to
a word that came up in that practice
quite often which is stuck
this idea of i mean at least i fancied
myself being self-aware
having a bit of insight obviously i went
to a whole lot of academic training on
how to
understand our emotional world in
particular and make sense and
obviously i employed myself as being the
helper and
the individual in the room helping
people break out
manage symptoms really heal and several
years into my
into my career i realized that i wasn't
so
great at doing that i realized again
like i said a really big pattern of
stuckness
a lot of difficulty with change with
helping individuals change
and also if i was being perfectly honest
with changing myself
so it really took i think a breaking
down of
the way i'd been thinking for a very
long time in terms of the human
you know being trained in the mind of
the human really just looking at that as
a separate entity
and so the holistic psychologist really
is an evolution of
really embracing the what i believe is
the interconnected nature that makes us
each human the mind yes the body
that the mind is you know connected to
and communicating with throughout the
day
and i'm of the belief that there's
another entity a soul
that kind of indescribable thing that
makes us us and
so what the holistic psychologist is for
me is really a tool and a platform to
begin to speak these truths and
talk about again the universal epidemic
of stuckness
and to hopefully provide some tools to
begin to actually create change
you have a book that's coming out you
can pre-order it right now in fact we'll
put a link to it in the show notes it's
called
how to do the work let's talk about this
a little bit
because i think we'd be remiss if we
didn't at least touch upon the subject
here so
so the subtitle is recognize your
patterns heal from the past
and create yourself and i saw that you
believe that trauma is at the root of
our current
mental health crisis can we talk about
that yeah absolutely so the stuckness
that i'm referring to
to a large extent is is very much
trauma-based for a lot of us
i believe that for a very long time
while in the 90s we did some research
and we came to
to develop this scale it's called the
aces scale
which really just means you know the big
bad things that happened to us
that many of us conceptualize as trauma
the abuse and neglect finally in the 80s
we
came to the conclusion after studying
this that
there are some long-term effects what
i've come to find in my
own personal and professional experience
is that that definition of trauma
is far more pervasive um you know
a lot of us have things that happen to
us early on typically in life
where we carry woundings we carry
adaptations essentially the way we've
dealt with all of this pain
and we become very patterned and very
habitual as creatures so that stuckness
that i was talking about
comes from that deeper programming a lot
of times like i was saying wrapped up
around
these wounds that i believe each of us
you know do suffer
as individuals and so what the book now
has become the instagram is where i show
up every day and
i talk about the journey of healing and
i put out the content and the free tools
so pretty much for anyone can begin to
meet this information understand maybe
themselves a little bit differently a
little bit deeper and do the work
the book now is the final place where
i'm so excited
because it's start to finish essentially
the whole
conceptualization of holistic psychology
like i said what makes us stuck what
keeps us stuck and how we can create
change
let's talk a bit about that trauma that
idea of trauma because
it's it's something that um as you said
we've
we understood it to be one thing as
we've you know over the last 40 years or
so
but it seems to me that like we talk
about it in terms of
repressing trauma or carrying it with us
um what what
how do we how do we unpack our trauma
yeah the biggest way we unpack because a
question i get a lot let's talk about
trauma
right a lot of times when we think of
trauma what most of us think of is right
the memory i know this thing happened i
can map
it back it caused this pain in my life
we might even know what we did to try
and cope or to feel better
that i think is what comes top of mind
and the reason why i talk about an
expanded definition just to share my
personal side of things is
i don't rank very high on that scale i
didn't have those big glaring kind of
things that happen that i know caused me
pain
and so for me i was a bit confused
because i was seeing still a lot of the
same
coping adaptations a lot of the same
tools
that didn't necessarily serve me i have
a pattern of dissociating of distancing
myself so
the reason why i talk about this is i
was confused i felt like something must
be wrong
uh because i was again like i said
struggling in the same ways that i was
seeing people struggle that had these
things so the reason why i describe that
is some of us don't have either the
experiences
of those traumas that happen and some of
us don't have
very much memory about past things that
happen and i very much
fall into that latter category if you
were to ask me about my childhood
i would have a very limited sense of
what happened or what did it and it
wasn't because it was so
catastrophically bad and i think that's
what a lot of us think of that i shut
down
it was just there was a slight overwhelm
that was kind of consistently there
that for a child it felt too much so i
bring that
up because when i'm asked about trauma
and those of us who don't have those
memories who can't pinpoint oh that
thing happened and that carried some
consequences
the way we can unpack our trauma to
simply answer the question
is to learn how to witness ourself in
our day-to-day life
and how to do so consciously because
everything that we're talking about
right now the trauma the way we cope
with it is
housed in a part of our brain or in our
mind that is called the subconscious
it's that autopilot that i think by now
many of us are familiar with i don't
think about life and i'm kind of going
through the motions
that it's from which that autopilot kind
of is
is running that we remain stuck in those
motions
because those motions are very patterned
so the way we unpack our trauma
is we teach ourself how to become
conscious to how we're showing up in the
world
with my belief in theory that our
patterns are visible
that everything i'm talking about all of
these ways we've learned to cope all of
these habits that aren't serving us
become visible to us when we're no
longer operating from that subconscious
so we can unpack our trauma in real time
by witnessing the effects of it in real
time
we've got some audience questions here i
was hoping maybe you could help us
answer a few questions i'd love to
diana and savannah georgia has a
question for us i have
made a few lifestyle changes that have
really helped me mentally emotionally
and physically
but i still find myself having what i
call bad mental health days where i
start questioning my abilities and lose
hope of myself
i feel stuck and it gets really hard to
get out of that pessimistic mentality
i was wondering if you guys have days
like that and if you do how do you deal
with them
how do you get out of your own head and
find the motivation and positivity to
keep pushing forward
nicole let's talk to diana about first i
hear this value judgment right at the
beginning i have these bad mental health
days
which presupposes there are good mental
health days and bad mental health days
i suspect you don't look at it that way
i actually
urge and suggest us all to redevelop a
new habit of not
passing judgment period getting rid of
good bad
should shouldn't another judgment we
love to cast upon ourselves so yes
simple answer
be as objective as possible things are
as they are
yes yes so what do you tell someone like
if diana were to come to you
and and talk to you about the pessimism
that she's feeling these
uh these bad mental health days uh what
how would you try to help her unpack
this
so peeling back the layer and we'll call
it distress right there's distress i'm
having a distressing day a stressful day
not bad
the first thing i would offer is it's
normal
right i think a lot of us think and i
think probably i was this person at one
time we have some expectation
of one feeling state forever more and we
just
that isn't what human is human we have a
breath of feelings the positive lack for
lack of a better
word end of the spectrum and negative so
there's fluctuation
we need to learn how to have a stressful
thing happen metabolize the stress
become stressed in our bodies if you
will and then return to baseline so the
first
offering i would make is that variation
in our human experiences
around our emotions is normal so
any of us that are thinking we're going
to avoid the more distressing side of
emotions
isn't the case with that said we can
really begin to understand
the role we're playing in terms of our
emotional world and what i mean when i
say that is you know if you are someone
so diana right maybe i know that i
ruminate maybe i can see that first
negative train of thinking oh today's a
no good very bad day then i just keep
repeating that
throughout the day the longer you repeat
for lack of a better word again a
negative thought
the the more chances that you're going
to have a body reaction
so we want to pay attention to how much
attention we're paying to our thinking
minds
because a lot of us continue to color
our experiences with the negativity i
could be that person
i wake up i have one negative thought
and if i'm not careful
i continue down a snowplow of negative
thoughts and before i know it by 12 pm
i feel negative so becoming aware
um and we can't stop our thoughts that's
something i want to offer right here
right now i think this is a good
teaching moment
so don't beat ourself up about the
thoughts that you're witnessing in our
mind
we want to learn how to give them less
attention meaning we can't shut them off
we all wish we could
when that first thought comes so if it
is a negative
thought if you will we want to practice
removing our
attention and the best place to put our
attention
to kind of piggyback what we were just
talking about consciousness
is in the current moment so we can use
our senses what am i seeing touching
tasting feeling can i focus on what i'm
feeling in this
moment instead of my maybe negative
based thought patterns
yeah i remember uh one time i missed
this phone call with
a man that i had set up a specific time
to talk to him
uh i was like two hours late to it and i
felt
so horrible and i was talking to him and
he could tell he's like dude you're
really stressed out about this aren't
you and i'm like yeah man
like this is something that shows up in
my life and uh yeah like i made this
commitment to you i feel really bad that
i broke it
and he was like if you want to uh earn
my forgiveness he's like i want you to
be kind to yourself
about this he's like that is that is a
how you can be forgiven by me but it was
the best advice
that i ever got because now when i find
myself having these bad days which
i do i have a lot of them uh instead of
getting caught in that spiral of
self-doubt or that self-judgment
um i try to talk to myself a little bit
kinder even if i screw up something
instead of beating myself up it's a
matter of like okay what can i learn
from this how can i
how can i be kind to myself through this
negative emotion uh one of the best
pieces of advice that i've ever had
what do you think about like physical
activities when someone is feeling down
for me
i know like sometimes just going on a
walk will help me feel a little bit
better getting out in the sun
exercising like if i can just get on i
have an exercise bike if i could get on
there for like 20 minutes i know that i
feel so much different afterwards
these aren't like miracle cures but they
are
uh they help they definitely help but
does does that
play a role at all with with these bad
days 100
i mean part of holistic is acknowledging
the connection between the mind and the
body
so just as much as we're all talking
about right my thoughts and i think most
listeners have that experience i think a
stressful thought
my body starts to release stress
hormones my heart rate might
start to increase i might tense my body
is sending messages to my mind
so for some of us and this is where it's
really individualized which is why
you'd never hear me proclaim universally
everyone do
this when we're sad or this one we're
angry because we all are different
energetically
yeah a lot of us though movement even
gentle
gentle stretching just moving we have
energies coursing through our body
at all times breathing walking it
doesn't have to be something strenuous
i know a lot of us are compromised
physically
however discharging our energy
physically can go a long way
to calm our body and then the signal
that our the message our mind will begin
to get
is one that's somewhat calmer than that
agitated energy so i'm like you
i've learned very begrudgingly so that
especially when i'm what
i label as agitated and that's gonna be
different for everyone else but what
i've come to know my body is
in agitation unfortunately i have to get
and take the walk
do the movement it's might be the last
thing i want to do
but again i just want to reiterate it's
very individualized this isn't me saying
everyone go out and have a run when
you're upset because
someone else that might not help
their energy feel more balanced that's
what most of us are looking for the
discharge of energy that's agitated
and allowing us to return back to
balance i love that idea of the
discharging of energy because with diana
here it sounds like
she's looking for a way to fix these
days and there isn't
there is no fix it is a matter of how
are you
dealing with these symptoms how are you
letting it pass through you so to speak
this energy
um instead of looking for a way to block
it it's diana maybe you want to ask
yourself
how can i let this energy flow through
me how can i discharge that energy
i love that too because you're really
highlighting something else which i get
just quickly
a lot of times a lot of talk about
bypassing right and and this isn't just
about think the happy thought diana or
anyone listening right it is actually
like you said about
releasing it to allow it to go a lot of
us get very good at stuffing it
yeah right that's not actually releasing
it so it's not just grab onto the next
happy thought
and hold on to it until you're happy
again for a lot of us it's find that
release for the negative crap
so that i can free up my energy to
return to balance to then
elevate into the more positive end so
just to be clear on that because i know
a lot of
some of us can listen to that and hear
oh bypassing don't ever focus and
i appreciate that you highlight it the
importance of letting the negative be
yeah i love what you're saying there
there is no fix there's only change
right if i were to make a pithy little
maxim there yeah
and because we are and what i love about
what you're talking about here nicole is
you're not offering the prescription you
know it's not the seven
step plan to be happy right because
we've tried all of those
and they haven't worked out for us very
well right we've tried the steps
and momentarily through chasing pleasure
or chasing happiness
we've achieved it momentarily but of
course it's always ephemeral and then
we're always let down because
oh wait i didn't achieve the state of
perpetual pleasure well it's because
that state doesn't
exist and the problem here
is actually the the solutions are
turned into the problem people like
diana and myself
and most of us we seek out the the fix
right and by seeking out the fix in many
cases it actually makes us more
discontent doesn't it
well diana i'm going to send you well we
can't send it to you yet but as soon as
it's available i'm going to send you a
copy
of nicole's book it's called how to do
the work we'll send you a copy of that
also have a link to it in the show notes
for anyone who is interested we have
another question here from
emily in houston my husband and i are
moving to london soon and side note i'm
having a fantastic time minimizing our
belongings
but i'm already stressed by the number
of people who are saying they're going
to come stay with us
i'm an outgoing introvert so while i
enjoy time out of the house with friends
and family
my home is my sanctuary i am fine with
immediate family and close friends
visiting every now and then my
philosophy being that if
i come to visit you not the city you
live in but you
then you are more than welcome to do the
same the problem is that my in-laws
friends and extended family most of whom
i have never met have already begun to
invite themselves to use our house as a
hotel
they only want to visit because they
want a free place to stay in london
not to spend time with us not only is
this offensive to me but i won't stand
for it this is not a hotel
it is my home and i am not a maid
preparing the guest room and cleaning up
after them will always fall on me and i
already have a full-time job
as i said my home is my sanctuary and i
do not want people who are not
extremely close to me or my husband
staying in it
so my question is how do i prevent this
from happening without angering my
husband's parents
or insulting those who are asking i
should mention that their family is
indian and my mother-in-law has told me
directly
this is just the way indians are i told
you to get a one-bedroom
how can i find a way to maintain the
peaceful life that i need
while also maintaining the peace nicole
i'm wondering what will you tell emily
here because she knows what she wants
and that's a beautiful thing
it's she's not on the fence what she's
worried about
and it's causing stress in her life and
probably in her marriage as well
is she's worried about offending
someone else and there's a certain
amount of attachment that she has
to that that feeling of i don't want to
offend
anyone ever do you see that in this at
all
oh i see that in this i see that very
common i see this in myself
and my history with my family i mean
this goes deep i'm hearing there's a
cultural component
um coming from a much more what we would
call individualistic culture
i mean at least her in-laws etc um
i want to answer this in a couple
different ways the first one of the
devastating ways first
which is that we can't control
what other people do the way their their
belief systems
are right i'm hearing a little bit of i
have this conceptualization right if
you're close enough and i stay with you
my home is open
right a lot of us tend to then project
our beliefs or the way we conceptualize
the world onto others meaning right we
assume that everyone else thinks the
same
so why are they you know then asking to
stay at my place when it's not
reciprocal in my definition
so the first answer that i'm gonna give
is we have to
you know we have to if we are someone
who holds expectations for others
that's the first practice right we want
to minimize the amount of times that
we're expecting others to view the world
as us to behave as us to think as us
etc the list goes on a lot of us do that
yes that's the first internal work
because you know outside
of even this relationship emily and
anyone else listening we do that all the
time i do it too
i project my meanings of words my belief
about what you should do in this moment
joshua
based on what i should do so that's
always practice
and maybe realizing here that there
isn't a should here either
and although it feels that way because
i'm so me
i've always i've only known me right um
it's the person i've been with my entire
life
and in that there's a lot of shoulds and
shouldn'ts
that i've defined you know either
on my own or because i've been
acculturated to do so
right but of course there isn't a should
or shouldn't the way that your parents
want to want the world to be isn't
right or wrong good or bad and the way
you want the world to be isn't right or
wrong good or bad
right yes yes i love that and i'm really
happy you you
you offered that at this point uh
because
that is true and it's part of the work
as far as i see it and i hope
the the book how to do the work will
help is one of those spiritual
or one of the traumas we talked about
earlier i define as a spiritual trauma
and this kind of
wraps in here is not having the space to
be
authentically expressed having so many
of those moments where we did share our
beliefs or
we just expressed ourselves in the world
and we were told some version of
shoulder shouldn't
so the goal i believe is to learn how to
hold space
for not only my belief in expression in
the world but for others to do the same
so as we heal
we are going to meet people especially
from our families a lot of us and that's
going to be where it gets complicated
where we do hear these should so the
first goal of the work is like you're
saying to extricate
the judgments right to understand that
we all have the space to
be as we are and to cultivate the
ability to let other people have that
space
that is not to say that we have to take
down what i call boundaries
that we can't have limits right so say
for instance to answer this question
directly
right emily can absolutely have a limit
of who she is comfortable with
staying in her actual home and whom she
isn't
right and it is absolutely emily's job
this is where
boundaries are an action for us to take
for us
it's our job to define our limit which
means then communicating
right whether it's through her through
the partner whoever how it gets
communicated
where those limits are whom i'm
comfortable with having in the home and
whom i'm not
and this is where i'm segwaying over
when i said i'm gonna answer the first
question
you know initially once i deliver the
limit and i tell the person you know
that
my what my home is not open at this time
or i just i would prefer to keep it to
my immediate family
the reaction that that other person has
unfortunately
right is isn't is not our responsibility
to tend to and this is where a lot of us
do ourselves a disservice
so i am the human who was so concerned
about what everyone else around me
wanted or needed
before i even got to the shoulder
showden's in my mind and i had a really
pivotal moment in my own healing journey
where i was asked what i wanted to do in
a similar context i had all these
requirements from all these people
around me and everyone thinking about
what i should do and my friend very
calmly looked across the table from me
wherever we were sitting and said
what do you want to do for this event
and i didn't even have
an answer so emily i want to commend you
listening though it might not feel like
you've already kind of done
a big portion of the work the fact that
you know what works for you and what
doesn't before we got to the step of
communicating it of course because
it sounds like that's where she's at
right right that i want to commend you
for that because i was a human a decade
ago who didn't
know i didn't know what i wanted because
i never practiced filtering through well
how does this feel for you
this event so that's the short of it and
so you were willing to
suffer to a great extent because
everyone else's expectations were thrust
upon you of course you can't meet
everyone's expectations
you can't even meet all your facebook
friends expectations let alone the world
writ large and so you were
in a constant state of of suffering in a
way because
you could never achieve this thing that
you set out to achieve
right suffering and exhaustion endless
exhaustion and then the byproduct of
this and
which is why i talk about it now and
boundaries and so anyone who's listening
and knows our limits well first
define our limits what are they what do
they need to be how can i
feel freer to be myself in these
relationships and then obviously once i
put them up
you know dealing with a lot of the feel
bad that happened maybe the very real
reactions
that happen because over time the more i
don't
put myself or even tend to my own needs
in
in any way the unfortunate byproduct
does come into my relationships because
what i tend to do and i'm speaking from
my own personal experience and patterns
i've seen in others
i tend to point my finger at everyone
around me whether you're not you're my
best friend
whether or not you're my family we share
a last name whether or not you're my
partner who i'm you know choosing to
spend my days with
i'm mad at you and you're the problem
you're not meeting my needs when really
i have to
point that finger back around and look
at each and every one of those
moments where either consciously or
unconsciously i overstepped my own needs
for everyone else
so it sounds like emily's mental health
isn't the only thing at stake it's
also her relationship with her husband
um i love what he said about boundaries
if
so she needs she needs her buy-in she
needs to understand what her boundaries
are but she also because she lives with
her husband has to understand what his
boundaries are
so uh emily you got to come up with
those boundaries with your husband
um but ultimately as long as you two are
on the same page
i feel like that's what matters most you
might you know uh peeves a few family
members or in-laws or friends of the
family
but ultimately you know i always feel
like
the people that truly love me and care
about me they're gonna support me
and if emily and her husband approach
this in a way of like hey look
i know that you love me and it's really
important for me
to uh have these boundaries and
all i need for you to do to support me
on these boundaries i mean the people
that truly love her and want her to be
happy will will probably end up
supporting her there might be a little
bit of a growing pain
um but but yeah i think those boundaries
are so much more important than just
throwing their hands in the air and be
like well i guess this is my life now
yeah i i would be careful with the being
on the same page thing i agree with you
i think
it's great if the two of them will be on
the same page if they aren't on the same
page
i would say the same thing to mla that
nicole said a moment ago
i wouldn't allow myself to be exhausted
or suffer
because you have to get on the same page
as him
oh right yeah and so i think the the
only person with whom you can be on the
same page as yourself
to a great extent and then if there's
overlap between you and your husband i
think that's
that's wonderful but you're going to
want to have those boundaries and if you
can get him on board not by
shaming or blaming as you alluded to a
moment ago but
by convincing him through showing the
benefits of
having your own you know your own
boundaries i think that's
uh i think it's gonna be really useful
for your relationship now hopefully ryan
yeah i hope that they can be on the same
page well i think with any relationship
i mean approaching it the metaphor with
what you just kind of said
you're never going to be on the same
page with anyone i mean technically i
mean
you are your own person uh maybe they're
in the same book maybe they can start
there
but uh but really you know it's about
emily
expressing to her husband hey this is
what i need for
my mental health me having good mental
health is gonna help our relationship
it's gonna help me actually get along
better with your family
um what do you think about that and he
might come from a different direction
well here's what i want i mean in just
like any relationship
there's gonna be some sort of compromise
and uh yeah so i i totally agree
in the sense that yeah don't stress
yourself out if you lay down these
boundaries
and then your husband and family says no
we're not going to do that
um you know don't don't beat yourself up
because they won't do exactly what
you're
what you're asking them to do um if you
do approach it in a way of like a
collaboration you probably could get to
a point where both sides are relatively
good with how things will go down in the
future with people visiting their house
yeah i would just say that she's not
asking her family to do anything
she's asking him to not do something
right and
don't break into my house essentially
and so
um i think that's the nice thing about
these boundaries here and i'm going to
leave it with this emily i'm going to
send you a copy of we have something
called the minimalist rule book
it's actually not a rule book we just
call it that because everyone's always
asking us for
definitive prescriptions and so we
called it 16 rules for living with less
but
we thought about just making it blank
400 pages right yeah no it's uh the
minimalist rule book 16 rules for living
with less it's it's free
on our website the minimalists.com rule
book there's also an audiobook version
there as well
but um what we do at the very beginning
we explain how there is
actually no rule book what we've done is
we've found some recipes that have
worked really well for me and ryan
you can adjust those recipes for taste
or not use any of the rules at all
if you'd like we're certainly not
prescribing anything to you emily but if
you want to check that out it's called
the minimalist rule book it's over at
the
minimalists.com rule book ryan what time
is it
you know what time it is it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 93720
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones and we respond to as many as we
can personally
but also we respond to some here on the
podcast so nicole if you can help us
here
we have a question from tj what can you
do
to promote healing in someone other than
yourself
i have a pithy answer for you so what we
try to do is we wrap it up and we call
these minimal maxims sean puts them in
the show notes so we can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media uh my
pithy answer here to tj what can i do to
promote healing in someone other than
myself
i say listening is the best medicine i
think that's one of the only things we
we can do because
i don't know this is the prescription
thing again like what what what can i do
how can i force my friend to heal and it
i i have trouble with that but i think i
know one thing you can do is listen
you can listen can we talk about the
power of listening yeah the power of
listening i mean listening is a practice
that's one way i definitely want to
offer as an answer
not a lot of us listen to listen um
more often than not and i mean i'll
speak for myself when i know
when i'm hearing someone speak at me my
mind is constantly making associations
oh i don't like what they said oh i
don't agree with that oh
absolutely not it's like this for me oh
well you know what actually it wasn't
like this when you said it was like
right so constantly
i'm now not listening i'm listening to
my own thoughts
listening is a skill that means again
those thoughts are going to happen
they're going to try to
color my conversation and learning how
just like we talked about earlier to
remove my attention from the hook of the
thoughts that i could go down this
rabbit hole and
bring it back to what's being said so
listening is that's
what we're talking about right expanding
holding space let me actually
hear you different human separate from
me and your thoughts without me coloring
what i hear you're saying with my own
past experience now i'm just hearing a
reflection of me
right back what would you tell what you
tell tj here
he wants to promote healing in someone
other than himself
so my answer to that and i know it's
it's not often the popular one it's
to focus on healing the self because
beautiful things happen
a couple directions this could go i
could heal and if i'm having a lot of
times this question is asked in the
context of what we perceive as a
difficult relationship
right i want you to change so i can
experience or that we can experience
this relationship differently
if i focus on myself the journey of
course is not as we all agree here not
one step shop of self-healing if i
begin to do the work on myself
i experience a relationship differently
the issue that i thought is no longer
and or i inspire the other person this
kind of comes back to the question we're
talking about last two right with emily
and
if i start to put up boundaries in my
relationship and
sometimes it only takes a bit of time
before the partner looks over and is
like oh wow
emily's starting to be you know inspired
or you know this question whatever
friend you want to inspire
as you start to shift and transform in
your life that could be
one of the most inspirational things
that actually might
um facilitate someone's entry into their
own
change but it's nothing we're going to
do or say or demand or threaten
which is i think the tactic a lot of us
take to create change so my answer is
always some version of the same which is
focus in
you show up differently and then change
happens without
there's a there's a dale carnegie quote
uh i think it's
a man convinced against his will is of
the same opinion still
and i think we have to think about that
this question in that respect
yeah yeah are you gonna conv do they
want to heal
if so then maybe you creating the
healing in yourself
or or being the the the paragon of
healing
for that person or just listening to
them heal themselves
yeah yeah but if you're convincing
someone
you're not actually healing them yeah i
think tj
tj is coming from a very loving spot
they see someone
that is hurting and they feel like
they should do everything they can to
try and fix that person from hurting i
go through this with
melbourne so melbourne has a lot of
health problems
and we could sit here and talk for
another half hour about all the health
problems he's experienced over the past
couple years
but i will see him and just think man
like
my brain starts to search for this
answer on what can i tell him to make
him feel a little bit better
but really you know i think the most
important thing we can do or the maybe
maybe it's always going to be the right
choice which is showing compassion which
which actually
leads into my pithy answer when in doubt
show compassion
so if all else fails and you have
someone who is in pain
if you can show them some compassion i
mean you can never go wrong doing that i
feel like
i'm really thank you for pointing that
out that is
i think the deepest we want to change
things around us
typically from a place of discomfort
right so thank you for
honoring that and honoring that aspect
of all of us when we see loved ones
especially the closer the relationship
the more time we spend
with them the closer they are to us of
course
is a very natural human part of each of
us that does want them to feel better
that does become pained when we see
someone else suffering and
that might be at a different place of
our own healing journeys and have maybe
have had incredible success
with something that maybe did sound
similar you know and you've he that's
an avenue a lot of us go down oh your
story sounds a lot like mayan
this is what worked for me i'm very well
intentioned in those moments i want you
to feel better just like i
am and again that's where we just can't
make those assumptions not
like you said very beautifully right not
two people aren't the same
um i think that's one of the deepest
existential crises if you will
of this human existence is going from
what truly believes
we believe is a separateness to this
more interconnected oneness and we keep
ourselves separate in a lot of ways
and the reality of it is in a lot of
ways we are separate we're different
but we can have space for all of us yeah
all right before we get into our
listener tips
and our added value segment today it
looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week what is the
potential of
post-traumatic growth ptg they're
calling this
how does one ever really heal from grief
can you if so how is the saying time
heals true
how can we learn to manage or eliminate
our innate desire for
closure and after forgiving someone for
a wrong doing is it okay
to not reconcile plus we've got a
million more questions about healing and
trauma
for dr nicole lepera and if you want to
hear all that subscribe to our maximal
episode
on the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not a private podcast
subscriber
you're literally missing more than half
of our show probably about two-thirds of
our show
plus hundreds of hours of past private
episodes so try it out for a week or a
month it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
head on over to
theminimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
private podcast plays and your favorite
podcast app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners
check them out hi guys my name's sally
from victoria australia
i wanted to share with you an app i
heard about on dan harris's
10 happier podcast ironic i know
but i'm trying to reduce the apps i have
on my phone i swear but i found this one
to be
quite meaningful the app's called we
croak
and for 99 cents uh you get a reminder
five times a day at random times that
you're going to die
i know this sounds a little grim but it
has truly had a really
positive impact on my day-to-day life
overall
i would say i've tried to embrace the
goal of living my life according to my
values
but on a daily basis i know i can easily
be troubled and distracted by the little
things
being randomly reminded throughout the
day that i'm going to die
has meant that in the moment i'm not
sweating the small stuff as much
i've noticed shifts in my behavior in
small ways i guess
say getting off twitter
more quickly when i find that i'm down
that rabbit hole
i'm putting down a book say that i'm not
enjoying
um or even like lighting a favorite
candle
just because for no reason and not
thinking that i should save it
for another day i don't know why i would
do that anyway
bigger reflections i've also noticed
such as
not caring so much about what people
think
i've found that i am moving on more
quickly from
mistakes that i've made and most
importantly to me
it's really emphasized on a daily basis
the connections that i have with the
people i love and how much i want to
focus on on those people hi ryan and
josh this is amanda from melbourne
about a year ago after listening to a
few of your podcasts
i decided to start decluttering my house
i struggled getting started though as
the whole task felt too overwhelming
luckily for me i had a good friend who
was in the same situation and we agreed
to join forces
for the last 12 months my friend sam and
i spent every friday together
alternating between her house and mine
helping each other work our way through
every cupboard shelf and storage area
some weeks have been really emotionally
stressful
some have seen us covered from head to
toe in dust
but we have donated and thrown away
hundreds of kilograms of no longer
needed items and have had a lot of fun
along the way
all right y'all thanks again to dr
nicole lapera for joining us today
her forthcoming book is called how to do
the work you can pre-order it now we'll
put a link to that in the show notes
we're also going to put a link
to her instagram account where millions
of people follow her it's really a
community
and so i'm going to encourage you to
follow her over there if you have
instagram or check out her youtube
channel we'll also put a link to her
youtube channel
in the show notes if you're looking for
more information about mental health or
healing i think she is a phenomenal
resource she really strikes me as
an enlightened person and we dive deep
in
the maximal episode about
healing and trauma but i would also
encourage you to check out
all of her work on instagram youtube etc
for added value this week since we're
talking about mental health right did
you watch the show euphoria
no it's on hbo and it's really a show
about teenage mental health and
you know how when we were teens we're
all volatile to
the people around us especially it's a
drama i'm assuming it is
okay yeah and and it really brings out
the peer pressure but modern day peer
pressure so it's a lot of
jinzy teenage kids
and it makes me think of big mouth on
netflix
right which is like i saw an episode of
that yeah and it's cartoon
yeah cartoons and it like deals but it
deals with these teenage angst and
mental health through through comedy and
stuff but this is a lot darker than that
okay
yeah but but it's it's a really great
show zendaya is the main character
um and she does a phenomenal job but
they just do a great job
dealing with modern day like you bring
technology into
the anxiety and the discontent of course
you bring drugs and sex and
and all of these sort of social media
yeah yeah
and not just social media but social
pressure right which is
is propagated by social media but even
without social media
dating apps and all of these other
things that
that didn't infect our childhood think
of all the stress and anxiety that we
had
when we were teenagers in the 90s and
and you
move that forward to today and it's
accelerated phenomenal show
dude i was thinking about how grateful i
am that we grew up
and went to high school without social
media yes um i feel very lucky actually
to like not go through high school with
that
but i don't even think about like the
dating app piece of it
because i mean just because you're in
high school doesn't mean that you don't
have access to that
right wow well the show is called
euphoria you can check it out on hbo
and real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
we don't have any tour dates on the
calendar right now but
you can check out our previous events if
you go to theminimalists.com
previous you know ryan we've been on
nine tours over the last 10 years yeah
and uh a lot of those events we have
either video or audio for those
or photos you can see photos from past
tours as well
it's really fun to go back i go but yeah
i go back every once in a while
yeah well especially like 2011 2012.
and you can see ryan's cargo shorts and
plaid shirts that we
would go on tour with and short hair oh
it was a different person it's like
matching white shirts it's like we
switched out the main character during
season three
no one has noticed yet that's right oh
my goodness that's so good actually
that's a really good yeah cause you look
the same today as you did then
i'm like yeah when i go back i'm like oh
my god i used to be so young
well now you're just wise advanced
i guess yeah the minimalist.com previous
if you want to see
previous tour dates over there you can
also subscribe for to our email list if
you want to be notified when we are
coming to a
city near you you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you whenever
those pop back up if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast
email a voice memo to podcasts at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode
youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday emails
whenever we send those but i can tell
you what we won't send you we'll never
send you spam or junk or advertisements
or penis picks guaranteed
or your money back oh my god if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it